>> Good afternoon everyone.
Good afternoon to those who are
in the room and to those who
are watching us remotely.
Today we have
our final intern project
of Anderson Avila who is
PhD student in
Institut National de la
Recherche Scientifique.
>> Very good.
>> In Canada, under the
supervision of Dr. Tiago Falk.
Today he's going to talk
about his intern project,
Audio Quality Assessment
with Deep Neural Networks.
Without further ado,
Anderson, you have the floor.
>> Thank you Ivan for
this nice introduction.
Thank you all of you for
watching my presentation.
This is the outline
of my presentation.
It starts with
a little introduction
on Audio Quality Assessment.
Then we dedicate some time
to explain our dataset
which took a massive amount
of time to develop,
and it's a really nice dataset.
Then we discuss
our proposed approach
for the plan of
Audio Quality Assessment,
and then the results
in the conclusion.
So, what is Audio
Quality Assessment?
The idea of the Audio
Quality Assessment
is to estimate the quality of
the audio based not just on
the signal attributes
such as SNR,
noise level, speech
level or reverberation,
but also considering
the human factor,
the human subjectiveness.
So, at the end,
we want a model that can give us
a number that we will
represent the quality.
Why this is important.
So, many multimedia
services network systems,
they need to be monitored,
and we can not just look at
the quality of the services
without considering
or taking into
consideration the end user.
What we could do was to have
a feedback from the end
user to monitor ourselves,
but this is not always happening.
So, an alternative is to
have a model that can tell
us how good is our service,
also considering
the perspective of the user.
So, at the end, we don't
want to predicting
a voice call and
avoid the user having
problems of not hearing
each other or not
being able to synchronize
the conversation.
So, all these things
can be monitored and
improved if you have
a feedback from the user.
So, these are some of
the possible existence of
network impairments that
can hinder a call
or can compromise the
quality of the audio.
So, latency, jitter, packet loss,
and on the signal side,
you can have speech
distortion, such as,
additive noise,
reverberation, clipping.
So, all these kinds
of artifacts can
hinder communication
based on audio.
So, how we can
actually assess the quality
of the audio there.
We have two alternatives.
One of them, is to have people
assessing the audio files.
So, we can have a
speech being recorded,
then people can listen to it,
and then each participant
can give a score,
then you get what's called MOS.
So, MOS is just the mean or
the average of all the scores,
and this is important
because it eliminates
the subjectiveness
of each individual.
So, each person has their own
reference of quality.
It depends on
many different aspects,
for instance, the person
is an expert,
they might be more rigid.
If the call or the audio or
the content is important,
it may also influence the score.
So, with the MOS,
we can eliminate these factors.
So, subjective listening test
is actually
the most reliable one,
but it has some drawbacks.
So, it's time-consuming, it's
laborious, it's expensive,
and I think one of
the things that is
really complicated is that
it cannot be done in real-time.
So, if we have a model
that can do this for you,
you can actually evaluate
your systems on the fly.
So, another alternative to
subjective listening test is to
compute MOS using an algorithm.
So, we replace the human by
a computer based algorithm.
We have two types of algorithms.
Can be signal based,
so the algorithm looks at
the signal and extract some
attribute operands of the signal
to estimate the quality.
We have a parametric base,
which use network parameters
to estimate the quality,
and you can have a hybrid one.
So, we can use
the signal without reference
to estimate the quality,
or we can use a double ended
one which use the reference.
So, you have the degraded signal,
the clean signal and then
you compare the two.
That's what PESQ does,
we are going to talk about
these metrics in a little bit.
So, these are some of
the mostly known metrics
or measures for
Audio Quality Assessment.
We have PESQ, a new version which
can be used for
wide band signal, POLQA.
These are all developed by
the ITU-T organization,
and you can see
that, for instance,
PESQ is more strained for
codecs and compressions,
not really for noise
and reverberation,
or the kind of environments
that we can have in the signal.
We actually have
some limitations,
therefore this is actually
the motivation for our project.
So, although PESQ is widely used,
it has some drawbacks.
It was not really
trained for distortions
introduced by
the speech compression,
but it is intrusive.
So, it needs the clean speech or
a reference speech to
compute the output.
So, our objective is to have
a new algorithm that can
be trained on
noise reverberation,
audio pipeline distortions,
and also that is not interesting.
So, these are the two main
things that we're looking for.
When you look at
the literature review,
where actually in this project,
we're focusing more on
deep learning approach
to build our model.
When you look at
the literature review,
we see that there
is a lot of work
on using deep learning
for predicting
mostly intelligibility,
but not really for speech
quality in general.
Most of these
approaches are based
on a speech recognition,
so they actually estimate
the quality considering
the performance
of the speech
recognition systems.
There are two approaches
that I thought was.
>> Most of the papers
are from this year.
>> Yes.
>> Except one. So, it's
a new thinking in the community.
>> Yes. Those are papers
that are recent papers.
They're focused on deep learning
to solve this problem,
but most of them focus
on intelligibility.
Intelligibility is
actually just one factor
or one aspect of quality.
So, this paper I thought
was interesting,
although it's also focused
on intelligibility.
But, the idea here is to
have a spectrogram of
your speech signal,
and then use a CNN
and their kernels
as a filter to estimate the MOS.
It actually eliminates some of
the engineering features that we
know by using a CNN as
a filter and as a kernel.
This one was also a paper that
I thought was interesting.
It's an end-to-end non-intrusive
speech quality assessment model,
and it uses a spectrogram
and a LSTM to
estimate the quality.
So, I thought it was
interesting that they built
actually their own cost
function, they customized it,
and to get the correlation
between each samples or
the sequence of samples here,
they estimate the
quality by frame.
So, usually what we have is
the overall quality for
the whole utterance,
and in this paper,
they actually were able to
export this information
to estimate the quality
of bi-frame and then get
the overall quality.
We'll now talk about
the data generation.
So, we had to spend
quite a few time
to try to generate
more realistic dataset with
different impairments.
We had initially a clean
speech, 2,000 files,
then we convert it with
different impulse response,
to simulate reverberation
distance talk.
We had the reverberant speech
samples, then added noise,
we had like four categories of
noise and with different SNR,
and also different speech
levels and noise levels.
We're going to show
all the statistics on the
data in a few slides.
At the end, we had
like 10,000 noise
samples and to train our model
we divide it this way.
So, I want to now talk a little
bit about how we labeled
the data. Before I just-
>> One question,
from previous slide.
Upper on that corner,
third line the random
noise level of 50 dB SPL,
deviation of zero degree
or it's a typo?
>> Yes, it's a typo.
It should be 10 dB.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, this
is just a model,
how the quantities
perceived by the humans.
They actually are
divided in three events.
The first event, is
the physical event,
is the waveform
which are the ears.
We perceive the sound then,
we have the perceptual event,
where we actually extracted
the features such
as loud noise reverberation.
So, we automatically extract
those information from the audio
and compare with
the desired features.
So, the design features
is the internal reference
that each person has,
and then we can make a judgment.
So, after doing the judgement,
we were able to estimate
the quality ourselves,
and then maybe have
a description of what effect
was played a role on
this mission of quality.
So, basically, this
is what will happen
when we have people rating
our speech file, our samples.
>> What is PJDD in the boxes?.
>> This is the perception,
to judgment, this
is the description.
So, we have the perception of
the physical event,
which are wave-forms.
We measured the
features internally.
So, that's the perceptual event.
We compared them with
the desired feature which
is your internal reference,
then you can make a judgment
how good is the quality.
So, the thing is that people
have different desired features.
So, we have different
expectations,
then we'll do the description.
So, the idea of the MOS is to
minimize or mitigate this device.
>> [inaudible].
>> So, he's like considering
the desired features
with reference
and here's just considering
the degraded signal.
So, here it would be like the
non-intrusive and here intrusive
because you have reference.
>> I see.
>> So, I thought it was
important to before
talking about
our listening tests or
our listening quality tests to
make clear what are
the effects that people
are listening to.
So, we have the
reverberant speech,
with RT60 ranging from
300 milliseconds to
500 milliseconds,
in our discussion was
the most common range
and had a close talk
and in anechoic speech.
So, in terms of SNR,
this is basically
the range of our SNR,
we're going to check
the distribution of
SNR in a few slides.
So, we have also noise and
speech level are varying.
So, all these variables
actually are
being assessed by people.
>> I have a question. So,
SNR changes as a huge range,
but your reviewer doesn't have
a huge range, why is that?
>> Well those are the
RT60 that we had at hand.
I think one of the things that we
discussed is these are
the most common type
of RT60 that you can find
in rooms like
such an office, in-house.
>> So, the higher that this.
>> I mean there are some,
like a treated office
will be 200 or 100,
and then my living room
is a thousand,
so why not go from a 100 to 1000?
From 0 to 40 dB SNR,
so that's a pretty good
range. Just curious.
>> Because this is
the impulse responses we have.
You guys gave us.
>> Also we have like
the Skype pipeline,
which apply enhancement
to all these impairments,
and actually we
divide the data-set
between 50 percent with
using the Skype pipelining,
50 percent not using it and we
see like there's an improvement.
It's like improvement
using the Skype pipeline.
>> What does it include
the Skype pipeline?
>> Is the ACG.
>> [inaudible].
>> Also the enhancement.
>> We have actually those some
non [inaudible] speech signals
which means zero.
>>Yes, yes comes at zero.
>> Yes.
>> You do have zero on it.
>> So, when you include the AGC,
what does output of this,
I mean this is it like SNR
being adjusted or what
happened after the Skype
pipeline was written out?
>> When you look at
the distribution of the MOS,
at least you see
a slight improvement.
It's not huge, but
it's actually doing
something in terms of
enhancing the signal.
>> So, if you don't do the AGC,
I would assume the signal
would saturate,
in some of these sounds
will saturate,
and the more successful
because of that?
I mean what is the reason
of doing the AGC,
why do you need that?
>> To analyse the performance
of the voice measurement AGC.
>> You need ADC because
somebody can be at one meter,
somebody can be at four meters.
This is four times difference
in the level of the audio,
the speech signal and
you need to equalize it,
before you send it
to the other party.
That's the first thing.
We did not do normalization when
you compute the RMS
and the entire file,
eventually multiply
it simply because
AGC introduces
its own distortions.
So, the gain goes
up and down based
on what he thinks when
we hear speech rotate,
we wanted those distortions
to be implanted into the signal.
So, to get users
to judge how much did it
take with this or not.
>> Did that affect the mass?
I wonder. Like he says
there was some change
in the mass like how?.
>> If there's from time to
time actually it's symbolic.
But, in most of
the cases it sinks.
>> So, AGC had a big impact
more than [inaudible]
ADC was an improvement
but my suggestion was
because I didn't
really think it works.
>> So, in general,
AGC with the voice
activity detector
slightly works quite well.
If the VAD misfires and
you have a noise signal
and consider it as
a voice substance
to wrap the voice flow,
and that doesn't sound well.
Or if somebody speaks
from far away,
and the wave is not far,
then the voice still stays weak.
This also is not very pleasant.
>> But in the realistic case
the AGC is still there.
Like in real case when people
are really using this type.
>> This user processes will
create the Skype pipeline,
The call which is [inaudible]
I think Benjamin.
>> Yes.
>> Okay so, this is what
coming to the participants.
So, for each condition
we had 10 participants.
So, we average over 10,
and then we get
the subjective scores.
So, not just getting the scores,
but also asking
the participants to
evaluate each one
of these effects.
Then we're going to see
how they relate to MOS.
>> So these effects
can be on or off.
>> Actually they're always on.
So, you have like
mixed effects here.
Not like its exclusive effect.
>> Okay.
>> So, this is actually the OHIS,
which is the outsource
company that provides
human resource for us to do
this kind of experiment.
So, people, the first thing that
they do they read the guideline,
they go through
a training where they
get familiarized with each
one of the imperiments,
noise, reverberation, et cetera.
Then they go to
a qualification part where
they go through
the experiment and
then we use a good standard file
so we know what to expect
from their ratings.
So after that, they go
to the test itself,
they listen to the
file after that,
these buttons are enabled so
they can rate from one to
five and then we ask them
which device they're
using and also
which imperiment was
mostly disturbing.
This is a little bit of
the Data Exploratory Analysis.
This is our MOS and
this is a PESQ,
and this is the SNR.
The SNR is supposed
to be like a normal,
so we actually added
a little bit more low SNR so
we get the MOS to shift a
little bit to the lower values.
The reason is because we
want our model to actually
learn how to rate also
this kind of situation.
But people were generous
when they were rating.
I was thinking that
because people were
not using our service,
they were working for
us so they tend to be,
I think that may play a fact.
>> If they thinking with
the actual number for that mass,
how do you derive that number?
>> We have to derive it
because remember we need
to average over 10 people or
even more to eliminate
the subjective needs or
the individual factors.
>> So, my question. Okay. So,
why aren't they underrated,
aren't supposed to be
correlated? PESQ and MOS?
>> So, PESQ is pretty behind.
>> PESQ.
>> So, that means PESQ is behind?
>> Well PESQ, the way
I see it is that PESQ,
you see mark close
to the SNR solution,
you look at only at the signal,
PESQ doesn't really look at
the subjectiveness of the.
>> It supposed to
look, right? I mean.
>> I don't think it
was trained for this.
>> It's not trained for this.
>> It's trained at to
it's only to evaluate
the distortions causing
the speech compression.
That was the initial idea behind.
So, you have codecs we
different abitrary,
different cortical,
corting salvalitmus which
means spelled them innately
relatively clean signal from
a form or cost of microphone.
You compress it, and
then you decompress it,
and then you have to
judge at the quality.
So, this is why even the traces
of noise make best to give you
a low score because these things
that the kodthec introduced
those huge noises there.
>> I don't know if my request.
We have brought in BESQ and
Poker remember like
in that expel,
they were quite
reasonably correlated.
>> So you'll see BESQ and MOSQ
from the judges have
0.7 correlation.
There correlation
is the same thing,
it's just the ARCAS
absolute value,
BESQ is more strict
and gives lower score
when you see noise.
When the voices is natural,
you may settle more for givic.
>> We use this for
speech enhancement
>> Yes.
>> Evaluation takes.
>> I don't have the full chapter
why BESQ is bad,
but we don't have anything
better than that.
So, this is the better thing.
>> Okay.
>> Just this point about the MOS.
I think if your people
are using our service,
there would be more
restricted with the MOS.
I think the fact
that they are kind
of getting paid to do this,
they might be more generous.
That's one assumption.
>> So, then you compare
this with expert ratings?
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so a little bit
more about the data.
So here we have MOS in SNR.
You see that MOS tends to
be correlated with the SNR.
So I'm not saying that
the costs for the SNR,
but it plays
some effect listener.
So, the noise level,
it seems like when
the noise level gets
higher people tends
to give a lower MOS
but is still like lower
is still like three,
right which is that's why you get
this shift MOS distribution.
For me, the way I see this
is people are more
concerned with the speech,
so they really can't hear it.
So, if the noise is
tolerable they don't
really care much.
>> So, wait a minute.
What is this?
Is that all 10 numbers
and that's the average?
>> Yes, so yes exactly.
>> It doesn't look like.
>> No this is actually
the MOS, is the MOS already.
>> No. What is that line
and what are those dots?
>> The line is like the
correlation, between the two.
>>The trend.
>> How they they vary together.
>> I think less into a year
you have interactions right,
between your variants so
correlation doesn't make.
>> Yes of course.
I mean just to have an idea
so here's not
the just the SNR there is.
That's why I showed
this slide here so
people know that these
things are on all the time.
So, you cannot
really just analyze
SNR and say that's the only fact.
>> Go back to that.
So, each dot should
be a file right?
>> Of course.
>> Each dots should be a
file yes, that's right.
>> So, each file gets
ready for 10 times.
That the value MOS should
be the average of that.
>> Yes yes.
>> This is why you
have every tenth.
>> The curve should just
be the mean of that.
>> What is that thing
around the curve that.
>> Should be a confidence symbol
where about this.
>> Yes.
>> But, in general
noise level per say is
not indicative because
under the same noise level,
if we have a level valvet or
softer speech signal you'll
get different results.
SNR is more indicative and
you see that it is actually.
>> Yes.
>> More.
>> Yes, but I was curious to
see how these three things
plays out considering you know,
because these things are
changing together we don't have
fixed speech or a noise,
so these are all
effects on the outcome.
>> So [inaudible] might not
hold if you look at the middle
and the third picture.
>> What is that?
>> Noise level and speech level.
>> Yes, I think the fact
that you actually see,
like, of course, there
are interactions,
but you cannot deny that
there's a correlation between.
>> In general, yes.
>> So-so, the speech level
doesn't mean anymore
than the noise level,
but the fact that
they're delivered at
the same absolute playback level,
it shows that, okay, if
you crank up the noise,
it doesn't really
matter as long as
the speech level is okay.
>> Yes, that's the point.
>> But I don't see that
in the third picture.
I would expect the third picture
would be the same
or similar to
the middle part. No?
>> No. Because, imagine
you have noise here,
but, you don't really care right?
Because you are being able
to understand or listen.
>> Okay.
>> So, that's why
as the speech level increases,
MOS is increased, so,
you have a better
level of speech.
So, it's more comfortable
for the listener.
I think we saw
that Chandan right?
I think one of
your comments was that,
that's why you're
always saying like
let's lower this pitch level
because that's
what people are getting
bothered with to
get the lower MOR.
>> Yeah. Low volumes have
the biggest impact on the MOS.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm just still concerned
about this distribution here.
It looks like the dots
are distributed all
over the place, right?
>>Yes, it's just one of
the abilities because
you know they have other
things going on here.
So, you cannot just say,
this is noisy MOS.
>> That's why it's
difficult to estimate here.
>> There's a lot of
interaction here.
We have all these things
but [inaudible] have
a Rawlsian networks properly
simulated with a lot of [inaudible]
packages-.
>> This is Xiao Gu money
when they go.
>> -those are the files.
>>I know people have elevated
down and we're computing
the mean range so that
seems to be at least 40.
>>Let's say you have a
file that is 20 DBSNR.
What this file they
can be distortions
from the speech enhancement
is called AGC,
they simulate to skype
through stimulated network.
Maybe, packages groping can
sample files which brings
the quality value.
So I think the
bottom line here is
that there were way
more factors impacting
the perception of the quality
than the personal which is
quite frequently used in
scientific papers as
the quality measure.
>>Yeah, I mean the point here
is just to say there's
some trend data and we can
actually extract some information
but we cannot say like
this is causality
between speech level and MRI
and here this is also i think is
interesting so this
is actually what
people reported as
more disturbing.
So, and then actually when they
report the noise
was more disturbing
noise was actually increasing
in terms of disturbance we
have a decrease in MOS.
So that's what people thought,
so, before was
the ground truth, right?
And here with reverb so as
Ross said maybe we should
have trained here
but these noise,
but this is what people said.
>>We have three judges of
thin clinking cold air
is noise in the file
you'll get 0.3 [inaudible]
because each just one, there is
a noise in the fall
is a resolution of
one bed because
you have 10 judges
think Lincolnian this
0.3 noise level.
>>Nobody went this isn't
this the wrong way
to blockade because
excessive should be
the only thing waiting
everything should
remain the same for
every point you have
to understand the trend if you
wonder study that
trembling in Los Angeles.
>>That is in the silence tree
but this is kind of
more practical thick
you have 10,000 miles.
>>I understand.
>>Combinations of
everything in there.
>>I mean, you cannot be
a nice and noisy place.
>>Still you can say that,
when pretty much everybody
hears the noise in the file.
This means you lost
one and a half points at MOS.
>>All the other factors
at play and just
not just that's fine.
>>You read to basically
eliminate them wherever
[inaudible] this
is the trend like.
>>Yeah. I think,
the problem I think we
can do that kind of exploration,
Jeff would have more
the more time you
get the data ready?
>>I will keep everything the same
distinct device level
and get the [inaudible].
>>Yeah, but we don't have that in
our data, that's the thing.
The way our data was
generated we have
mixed effects in the day that's
what people are hearing.
We can what we can do is when
plotting it we can
maybe get the SNR with
one range and then
get the other- but
the SNR is random so,
if given within that range we're
going to have some variability.
>>But actually, if you just took
all the files that
were only noise
was it doesn't look nice.
>>But that's the thing
we don't have that,
because people have
the option to- to that's,
you see this is not
is not exclusive,
so you can hear noise and
because that's what is in
the file Noise Regulation.
Have mixed effects.
>>What if you keep
only the files,
No [inaudible] ,
and no [inaudible].
>>That's [inaudible]
because you have-.
>> [inaudible] People who are
totally Reuters people
will list the laws
the lower volume double-negative
[inaudible] but [inaudible]
more than that so,
we still have to
do some. Awesome.
>>I guess, the question
you're asking here is
for people to tell you
what you already know,
you put the noise
in the [inaudible]
in that you're just asking
people how well are you
able to correlate
your own judgments
of what their condition
was but in the end,
you probably don't care
about whether people
thought there
was too much [inaudible].
>> I think this does actually.
Natural speech hurts most
the perception of the world.
You see you can
get two points for
natural reverb is less
than a point, yes,
at some point more and more
people [inaudible] but they don't
punish that much and MOS
is somewhere in between.
Which might just be
an indication that remote
my math is not something people
think about money
will all school.
Maybe. And that's again
that there is
a ground truth you know
how much reverb was
actually eliminate.
>>Joe maybe just
less annoying for
humans or even a thousand seconds
is here this is this is
true yes which is pretty
much [inaudible] so
they don't get much
[inaudible] by the distortion.
>> So, let's go to
the proposed approach.
The first approach that we
thought was using I-vector.
So, the vector has been widely
used for recognition tasks.
So that was one of
the motivation.
So, has been used for a
speaker vilification,
language recognition,
emotion recognition
and the question was,
what about speech quality?
So you use I-vector for that?
I-vectors they are known to carry
speaker and also
channel variability.
The way you can think
about the I-vector Is,
you extract several observations
from your speech file,
usually MFCCs.
The bottom line is
where want to map
those features into a
utterance level vector,
which is the I-vector.
So we want to map them in
this total variability space.
So the way we do that is,
first you compute
the GMM-UBM model.
So, this background model we have
bunch of speech files
and it's going
to be a reference or like
a mean in this space here.
After computing the GMM-UBM,
you extract some statistics
from each one of
your observations here.
So, you get what is
called the super vector.
So, the super vector is
composed by the
components of your GMM,
and the features that
you have in your
feature extraction.
So, these super vector here
is what you are going to use
to compute the I-vector.
So m here means
independent super vector,
which comes from the GMM,
and you have the
dependent super vector.
So the dependent super vector
depends on your speech files.
Every new speech file,
you are going to compute
the offset from the GMM-UBM,
which is mean I-vector.
To do that you have
also to compute
the low-rank liability matrix,
which is the T-matrix.
We use the UBM and the Baum
Welch statistics to do that.
So this is the framework for
the I-vector effort,
preparing this framework,
we extract the I-vector for
each utterance in the train set,
in devset, and in testset.
So here are some plots of
the I-vector projecting
the clean speech,
which is the dark blue dots
here and MOS below 0.5.
So, you see that it projects
the I-vector and can actually
separate the two sets.
So, here's considering MOS
between two and three.
When we consider actually
the two levels of MOS
with the clean speech,
we see that the data gets
a little bit mixed up.
There's some clustering here,
but there's some limitations.
So, then we thought maybe you can
use I-vectors combined with
a DNN MLP architecture
to find a better
representation to compute MOS.
So this is the architecture
that we proposed.
We have I-vectors
of 400 dimensions.
I have a two hidden layers,
200 hidden units first layer
and the second layer used,
dropout for as
regularization and relu as
the activation
function and then we
predict the MOS with this model.
So, the second approach
was using what is called a
Q cepstral coefficients.
Again, it has been
used in bass cleaning
speaker verification to
detect natural and
unnatural speech
and has been very
successful in that.
So that was one of
the motivations.
The other one is that, it's
psychoacoustic motivated.
So, the idea of the constants
cepstral coefficients
is they say that
this Q or the quality factor
increases as the center
frequency increases.
So as you go up,
this factor will increase because
the window length that you
extract your samples
they are fixed.
So what they propose is to make
this Q factor constant
and change this,
so that this doesn't change.
So, the motivation for
that is that we're going
to get a spectrum.
There is a better resolution
for high frequencies
and low frequencies.
So, that's how it
would look like.
So, you'd have this spectrum
using their model, the CQT.
So, this is how it's computed.
So, we compute
the spectrum but we are
using the Q transform,
the power spectrum, the log,
and this is actually
a spectral feature.
So, they had to change the scale,
the log scale and
they do that by using
this uniform and then they
compute the deception.
We use two approaches
for these features.
The first one using
cepstral and the second one
using this spectrum.
So, if we remove
the signal process
computation of the spectrum,
we know that cepstral features
are very well established.
But if you let the DNN look
at directly on the spectrum,
would you get better results?
There was actually
the question here.
So this is our evaluation.
We use evolution setup.
So we use the Pearson
correlation and
the mean-square error
to compare the models.
As baseline, we use MOS
and we compare also our results
with SRMR, P563, and PESQ.
So, SRMR is also
a measure for estimating
reverberation and we want to
see if they can also be able
to estimate the quality
for the impairments
that we had and P563 is another
metric, is [inaudible] metric.
>> What's this P563, is this-
>> Yeah. It's a [inaudible].
>> Recommendation,
feedback [inaudible].
>> Mmhmm.
>> Okay.
>> So, all the results are
based on the test set.
>> [inaudible]?
>> No, we tried but we
didn't get rid of it.
I didn't get a graph of it, but-
>> You didn't get what?
>> We didn't have
the code for that.
>> I had it. You
should have asked me.
>>Oh, really? Oh my God. Okay.
>> That's two hours [inaudible] .
>> So, maybe next summer.
Okay. So, this is the results
for the I-vector,
and actually it's pretty similar
to the results we get with
the CNN on Cepstral Coefficients
using the Q constant,
and one thing I was
thinking here is that,
so I-vector is projecting
Cepstral features
or MACCs to the total
variability space,
and the CNN is basically
doing the same thing here.
So, that may explain why
the results are very close.
So, this was a bit
surprising for me.
So, actually removing one signal
process computation we
get better results just
looking at the spectrum.
And then, we have [inaudible] to
compare with the SRMR and P563.
We also explored with the help
of David and Harness,
another structure
using MEL features
in a full connect MLP,
and got a pretty
good results here.
So, the other thing
that we explored
was using these same
structure here,
which is computing the MOS on
a utterance level, but using-
>> The frame.
>> -on the frame level, here?
Okay. So, what we
did was to compute
here the - we use
all the features here on
the frame level as an input for
an ELM and extract
some statistics from
the ELM to get the results.
What we found is that the ELM
actually helps to decrease
the variability of the data
from 0.28, 22 to 0.17.
>> [inaudible] CNN.
>> In the- how you get
the results per file
because the fully
connected network
gets a segment of the thing.
In this case. So, you got
you have a segment movement
get a certain number where
you call them equations.
How you compute them here
for the entire frame?
>> For the utterance we
just take all the frames
over in the utterance and that's
what's passed a bit
[inaudible] passed the ELM.
>> Here, yes I know. But Here?
>> But that's also the that's
per utterance results.
>> How do you get the number for
the utterance here mileage?
What do you do?
>> It's just correlation-.
>> He's telling you get a
correlation per frame? [inaudible].
>> All the frame-
>> Per segment. So, you
cannot just network
or I mean call
a segment of 25 frames and
then next, next, next, next.
>> Right.
>> And you have a bunch of
numbers which is variable in.
How you compute the moment
for the utterance here?
>> As the result network,
we just looked at
all the frames that were in
the utterance maybe at
25 frames between
25 actual physical frame-
>> Segment by segment?
>> [inaudible] . So, each of
those what we call
the 1450 Vector Frame.
Each of those frames we
just worked at the core,
what was the result,
what was the loss estimation
on that and which
is the correlation over
plus all those frames.
>> All of them??
>> The utterance
level before the ELM,
then the utterance
level after the ELM.
>> So, pretty much
this is one solution?
>> Yeah.
>> This just tells us how
much [inaudible] Okay.
>> [inaudible] those are,
everything's utterance based
on clubs and that's
also utterance based.
>> So, pretty much
the all [inaudible]?
>> So, my question is
what is MSE [inaudible]?
>> Sorry?
>> MSE is compared between
one or two things?
>> Yes. The ground truth which is
the MOS and the inner prediction.
>> MOS is one number,
right? And-.
>> Yeah, but we have- okay
in the test set you have,
in my case I have 1500-.
>> On the [inaudible]?
>> Yeah. So, ELM is-.
>> [inaudible] 0.17 ACP-
>> No.
>> Guess estimation of how-.
>> This is just the
Pearson correlation.
> No MSE. So, in
estimation is about 0.2
meaning if the best is
2.5 or mass is 2.5 then is
estimating the 2.7 to 2.3.
>> Roughly yes?
>> That's what I mean sir.
>> Yup.
>> And also do we have
a estimation of
how well humans do?
>> No.
>> Humorous mean [inaudible] .
>> Yeah, well we should get
the data couple days ago.
>> No, we have the data right?
>> Yeah.
>> But we didn't find people
have even 10 members.
>> Yeah that's right.
>> Output this range
for those 10 people.
>> Yeah.
>> I'd love to hear one more line
humorous [inaudible]. One point.
So, technically
10 people on average
10 people get around
0.3 meter square,
square of 10 times less,
so technically this means
that if you will get
the 0.17 or 0.16.
You are as good 50-ish people
doing most tests?
>> If it's [inaudible] but nobody
knows that. That's empirical.
>> Still not bad.
>> What was the
difference again on
the second and third
models? [inaudible] .
>> Okay. So, this one is
looking at the cepstrum,
so you compute
the spectrum and then you
compute the cepstrum and
then use the [inaudible].
So, this one is
just an spectrum, yeah.
>> So, you let the [inaudible].
>> That's right, yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So, just to
conclude we develop
a new audio quality data set with
labeled and I think
it's very realistic
data sets and we can
explore a lot of
things on this data.
We explore also the effects
of mixing impairments on MOS,
we explore three approaches
to estimate MOS
and we show that
our methods outperform
all the baseline methods.
So, the next steps.
So, we want to
investigate- maybe
the combination of
I-vectors with
Q Cespstral features,
see if you can get
better results.
We definitely need to
utilize our Algorithms in
new data sets and we want to
explore more new network
architectures, end-to-end DNN.
So, we want to explore
a little bit more the DNN
plus ELM and CNN plus ELM.
And so, I'd like to say
a special thank you for
the Skype teams of
Gehrke was a great help,
Ross as well, with
great discussions I learned
a lot in this internship.
I'd like to thank you
all the people that
supported, funded,
Johannes and Scott,
Hannes Gamper,
David Johnston, who he helped
a lot also with technical.
Your technical
expertise was really
nice to have you guys,
and the whole Audio
and Acoustcis Research Group
especially Van was
really nice was always
there when I needed and that
was a great time for me.
>> Questions. It was
actually quite nice discussion
during the talk,
but if you have more questions,
please ask comment.
>> I think one of the main things
to do in this exactly to do what,
[inaudible] was
suggesting, right,
is to get expert opinion on this,
because people are
giving some MOS scores.
But it might just
be random. I know
how reliable they are because
these people are just people.
>> But there's not
the point though.
>> No, you also want to get
an expert opinion to see.
>> What is an expert opinion?
I play a sound file that has
five different distortions.
You can say based on
my expert opinion,
I think that's
500 milliseconds revert.
That might actually impair
your judgment because
now you're basing
your judgment based on
what you hear in a file,
not what you might
proceed when you
have an actual phone
call with your-
>> That is fair. But at
least it's going to give
you metric to say how much
is the variance around.
Basically, if
the 10 people marking
the MOS score varies from
one to five, then
it is this nice.
>> Like you said,
it was one point
standard deviation,
which means typically in
MOS, Skype MOS scales.
Our variance or standard
deviation is one.
>> Right.
>> But here I don't
know how much was
the standard deviation, right?
So the standard
deviation is about
five here, right,
and it's useless.
>> Yeah.
>> I think 0.7, 0.7.
>> Is it 0.7?
>> Yeah.
>> So, the reason
I was suggesting
getting experts to check
some of the ratings
because it looks like
you have a central bias.
So, things are kind of
centered around three to
four relevance for now.
If you ask a bunch of experts,
they shouldn't have this bias.
>> Yeah.
>> So-
>> You'll hear more impairments,
the regular impairments.
>> Well, it's critical whereas
a naive writer will tend to
rate the mean of the central
tendency bias of string.
>> I think this kind of will
never be really realistic.
We tried to do as much as we can.
One thing that I was thinking
is different when you're
listening to an audio,
and when you are having
a conversation using
Skype service.
So, then and if you're paying
the services is even worse.
But there you're getting
paid to do that.
So, I think that also my-.
>> No. Definitely data
is so important, right?
There are companies who were
just selling data to ITU-T,
and their job is to just collect
data for MOS evaluation,
and you're doing it
for three months,
it's a good achievement.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. They're are
doing as much as they can.
>> One question.
How much cleaning of
the data that you have?
Are there any consistency
checks that you
find bad writers have thrown out?
>> We didn't actually did
much of that actually.
We didn't have standard alone.
>> So, if some letters
vary too much time from
the mean so they got standard.
>> Okay.
>> That was actually one of
the problems and we stop
getting the hits at
seven point because most
of the work is done by-
>> You mean like during
the test or after?
It could be post test.
>> Yeah, the
post processing, right?
>> Yeah.
>> We didn't have time
to do post processing,
which I had to kind of.
>> What were you doing
during the test?
And [inaudible].
>> So, when you had 10 judges,
and everybody disagree
on everything.
You still calculated the average?
>> Yeah. I think there's a lot of
variability in this
data for sure.
>> But it help if
you then look at
each judge of the special schema,
multiple samples,
[inaudible] samples,
if you look at what actually
is ranges and then-
>> What we have done this
is the motion detector.
>> So one of the thing
is like if you
check the ITU-T
recommendation for distress,
it says should start with
the conditions that you
want to do this experiment.
So, the condition
would be very clear.
People should not have
second guess about
what they are hearing.
But this is not realistic.
You're not going to
be an environment
with only reverberation
or only noise.
So, that's what I think was
the challenge of this dataset,
to have something realistic
at least on that side
of the impairment.
>> Maybe one consistency to
check that could be added
would be you also
ask the same rater,
given the same file,
and make sure they're
rating at the same,
that they're off
by a huge number.
>> Okay.
>> They're not reliable.
>> Yeah.
>> One small comment
since you collected
what people used to listen
to, the sound rules,
there might be some interaction
between- if they are
listening over speakers,
and the speech level is low,
then just rounds in
your environmental noise.
The noise levels being more
or high doesn't have much.
>> Yeah. That's right yeah.
>> Or just seeing-
>> But also data mining
we can do on those.
>> Yeah.
>> One hundred
thousands journals.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that-.
>> All the procedures
just drawing out
all the speaker based ones
and see what is.
>> Is there no way to buy
this kind of data from somewhere?
>> It is which is
more costly, $10,000.
>> Or whatever,
people would have done this
more rigorously, right?
>> No.
>> I mean, there's
this company which does POLQA.
Which develops
all this PESQ and all that.
What is the company's name?
It's in Europe or somewhere?
>> HEAD acoustics.
>> No, Opticom.
>> Opticom.
>> HEAD acoustics is also-.
>> It also makes control
software, but they don't.
So, are selling $50,000 or
$100,000 equipment
to do lab tests.
>> They don't sell data?
>> Opticom will sell you POLQA.
No one actually sells
data to do this.
>> You don't know if it suitable.
The data is suitable for Europe?
>> The actual Skype pipeline,
so whatever they did is
very, very Skype relevant.
>> Yes. Skype relevant also.
>> So, more questions?
>> I had a comment close
to what you just said,
I think all this averaging
might be queuing the application
because we really don't want to
average all these opinions,
if your intended
application is for
a telephone versus quality
versus Skype in a conference
on quality versus
Skype at home quality.
So, definitely what's-
>> Yeah, this is something I think
[inaudible] was saying, right?
But then you cannot
call it MOS anymore.
You've to call it
something else I guess.
>> But the average must be more-
>> Yes, on one hand.
On the other hand,
do you really get
valuable information?
Is more tailored to
your application?
I guess that's the-
>> I don't know because the IT2,
they say should have
like 20 people.
We got 10. These enough for 10,
like in our experience.
>> So, your deviation
of the average is way
lower than humans.
So technically,
presumably you get
better results down
a bunch of humans,
and I just estimated 0.16
mean square error will be
added to one of a single human
is equivalent that this 0.16
is equal to test with 40.
>> Okay.
>> Square root of one over n is
the number if they
need the statistics.
Okay. But that's
pretty much means that
each measurement with
this tool is equal
to MOS with 40 humans.
>> Okay.
>> More questions?
>> Again one question
to this slide we show
the correlation
between SNR and MOS.
So, that was the correlation
between the SNR,
how you generated the data?
>> Yeah, this the actual.
>> So, would be interesting to
see the correlation if your
compute SNR at the output,
which also then
contains like takes
the impairment of the processing,
and all these artifacts,
and cache logs, and these
things into account,
and that will probably
expected to be
this so much higher correlation.
>> So, SNR are what?
The input of the pipeline
or the output?
>> The input.
>> So technically, it's
actually SNR is here,
because the Skype
pipeline cuts this.
>> Yeah. Actually, 50 percent
of the data is
without the pipeline.
So, we actually could check
the difference at least.
>> In the call of 20 dB SNR,
the files with 20 dB input SNR,
and the files with
20 dB input SNR but
process it by Skype by
a time which means
the output is let see,
assuming 10 dB, SNR improvement.
They're actually at
the 30 dB vertical.
Yes, Sebastian is right.
If you measure exactly,
and that's pretty
straightforward engine.
But still in SNR,
it's is a poor quality indicate.
It's the easiest thing.
>> That could actually
be added to the list of
estimators just SNR predictor.
But the SNR at the output.
>> It's actually hard to compute
real time, CPU compute here.
>> Because we have
the clean speech file,
and we do the clean
speech and then estimate.
>> Not practical to
computer in our own system.
>> Yeah. Just as a reference
point for comparison.
>> One more question. So, use
the constant 10 samples
or 10 ratings per file.
But a reality that should
probably be adaptive because
different noise levels,
different impairment types will
require more ratings
or less ratings.
>> Okay.
>> So, humans are not
consistent across
all different types of files.
>> Okay.
>> So, you can use your data
to figure out which,
how many samples you need.
>> Okay. For impairment?
>> That's right..
>> Okay.
There is a lot of data to
play with for a long time.
>> More questions. If
not, let's stop speaking.
>> Thank you.